this is this is wild so check this out
so they've lost about four billion
dollars this is video that a guy who is
an Anheuser-Busch affiliate so he's one
of the guys that brings the the beer you
know because they don't have
Anheuser-Busch plants everywhere so they
have these Affiliates that bring the
beer to the stores all over the country
uh and here's a guy doing a selfie video
talking about how the the lack of sales
now because of this Dylan Mulvaney trans
nonsense inclusivity in light beer uh
what it's doing to his business
um I work for an affiliate company I am
a merchandiser
and the sole product of the company I
work for is anheuser-brush products
so with all this canceling going on
um
there's I mean I've never seen such
little sales in this past few days on
these products it's it's sad because
[Music]
people don't buy this beer
I don't make money
and I can't feed my family
so it's kind of uh
heartbreaking I guess
that um
Anheuser-Busch did what they did
they don't know their clientele
so it's uh kind of heartbreaking
[Music]
thanks Anheuser-Busch I may not be able
to feed my family coming up here soon
so obviously the the may not be able to
feed my family that's the that's the
banner one on that and hopefully he'll
find another job with a better
distributor but again this goes to the
point they don't know their audience or
they're ashamed of Their audience
because these walksters don't want white
Frat Boys drinking their beer and call
me crazy but if I was in charge of a
beer company I wouldn't care who's
drinking the beer if I saw a lot of beer
being sold and drank all over the
country I wouldn't be going well how
many white people are drinking our beer
how many Lesbos are drinking our beer
how many uh trans people and how many
gays like it's so nonsensical but that
is why the woke mind virus infects and
destroys the host almost without
exception
thank you
foreign
[Music]